premiers invités de cette édition du 7 8
daniel fournier bonsoir vous êtes élue
d'opposition ancien élu d'opposition
sans étiquette démissionnaire donc du
groupe agir pour saint cyr à
saint-cyr-l'ecole vous étiez au conseil
municipal de cette commune depuis 1986
pourquoi 89 vous ajoutez trois ans
pourquoi avoir décidé de quitter votre
poste avant la fin du mandat au mois de
mars on une expression passer le relais
vous voulez dire ça fait quand même
longtemps que je suis conseiller
municipal dans la politique la vie
associative et je sais que je quitterais
saint cyr au cours du mandat qui
débutera à partir de 2014 donc qui
n'était plus question pour moi ni le
modéliste ni d'être conseiller municipal
donc l'idée c'est en fait est bien de de
prendre un petit peu de recul bach de
façon à ce que d'autres puissent se
mettre en avant et préparer l'avenir
alors vous nous expliquer que de toute
façon vous ne vous seriez pas présenter
en 2014 parce que vous avez de toute
façon quitter saint cyr l'école pour
autant vous auriez pu terminer votre
mandat jusqu'en mars oui elle resterait
plus loin tout à fait mais je prendrai
un exemple ce qu'a fait le maire de
plaisir qui s'est retirée un an avant
je crois que quand on
on a eu un engagement durant de longues
années on comprend qu'il est important
de ne pas s'accrocher et de mettre en
évidence ceux qui continueront ce qu'on
a entrepris tout ce que vous avez décidé
d'orner déjà de dd justement là
l'opposition éventuellement obtenir
cette mairie en mars 2014 ou alors pour
l'instant vous êtes plutôt dans une
position d'attenté parce qu'il se dit
aussi qu'il y à quelques tensions et
vous n'avez certainement pas me
contredire là dessus avec une autre
partie de l'opposition un autre groupe
qui est relié par l'élu divers droite
etienne erasmus lui sera candidat vous
auriez souhaité peut-être un autre
candidat pour mener l'opposition c'est
bien ça
pas exactement dans le déroulé des
choses c'est que dans un premier temps
et pendant non plus neuf mois on a
essayé de l'aider à être candidat et le
bilan qu'on en fait c'est que il n'a pas
l'état d'esprit la volonté et la
disponibilité non plus
pour faire quelque chose de très
difficile qui est de mener une liste il
a été candidat aux cantonales mais
regardez où cantonales vous avez
facilement dix candidats aux municipales
vous avez de lys trois listes quatre
lits cet exceptionnel dans nos petites
villes pourquoi c'est excessivement
difficile c'est un exercice que j'ai
pratiqué en 2001 avec francis courtois
et
didier donnât c'est un exercice que j'ai
pratiqué en 2008 en est en tête de liste
j'en connais la difficulté vous avez
réuni 14 96% des voix votre liste est
arrivée troisième sur les trois listes
qui se présentait derrière la liste donc
du socialiste marc sadoun 34 48 % qui a
quitté d'ailleurs la commune de pluie et
puis 50,56 % pour le maire qui a été vu
vers noir de bain qui menait la liste de
de l'ump pour en revenir à votre
situation vous nous expliquer qu etienne
et racé non ce n'est pas l'homme de la
situation pour votre groupe d'opposition
qui se situerait plutôt sur l'échiquier
politique sans étiquette centre droit
alors nous allons reproduire ce que nous
avons fait en 2008 c'est à dire une
liste réellement rassemblant des
sensibilités tout à fait diverses donc
ça c'est la volonté c'est ce qui nous
nous regroupe la volonté de faire une
liste à partir du pro des problèmes
quotidiens des saint cyriens et non pas
à partir d'une légitimité qui viendrait
de partis politiques donc ça c'est un
sas que vous souhaitez avec les avec
quelle tête de liste alors parce
qu'alors pour l'instant ce qui s'est
passé il avait un premier temps comme
jouer on comptait un peu sur etienne et
ghazi mu bon on a un peu d'expérience on
considère que ça n'aboutira pas donc on
est encore un an maintenant un peu moins
d'un an des élections on avait encore un
peu de temps mais fallait réagir très
clairement tous les regards se sont
portés vers une personne qui est gaétane
desjardins qui est une ancienne première
adjointe dont il a parfaitement
l'expérience de la gestion d'une ville
qui est quelqu'un de disponible qui est
quelqu'un qui est sur le terrain depuis
au moins 2001 qui a l'art est-il la 23e
elle n'a pas de 2,2 d'étiquettes j'irai
si on veut la mettre sur le l'échiquier
politique je pense qu'elle me
démentirait pas si je parlerai de centre
droit mais donc la tête de liste à celle
je dirais ce profil politique mais elle
sait très bien que moi je les fais en
2008 que elle va mener une liste avec
des sensibilités beaucoup plus large de
droite de gauche et surtout beaucoup de
gens qui sont en fait dans la vraie
légitimité c'est ce qu'ils ont fait dans
la ville de saint cyr depuis les années
vous souhaiteriez cette tête de liste
pour l'instant elle ne s'est pas déclaré
un autre candidat lui s'est déclaré en
revanche etienne erasmus nous sommes
allés le rencontrer et les réagi à votre
démission notamment mais principalement
aux différentes remarques que vous avez
pu faire sur sa légitimité c'est au
micro de catherine mulato et de patrick
jacques de dixmude et lyon certain
nombre de choses de dites et écrites moi
je laisse à daniel pharr nier la
responsabilité de ce qu'il a dit et
écrit pour ma part je considère qu'il y
a toujours des opportunités dans la
perspective des municipales de 2014 des
réponses à apporter aux attentes des
saint cyriens l essentiel pour moi se
trouve là et va dans les petites phrases
ou dans les commentaires ici ce qu'on
sent bien là aussi dans les échanges que
nous avons été saint cyrien que le
clivage traditionnel si on peut dire
droite gauche ne répondent pas forcément
tout cas pas complètement aux attentes
et je pense qu'entre les deux listes
prévisible l'union de la gauche pour
faire simple et ump d'autre part il ya
une vraie opportunité un vrai champ
politique a occupé pour répondre là
encore aux attentes et aux
interrogations des saint cyrice ainsi
révolu mais je crois qu'il ya vraiment
des réponses apportées c'est un moment
important dans la vie de la commune il
semble finalement assez d'accord avec
vous entre la droite de la gauche une
liste au centre et à la place oui lui
estime qu'il est légitime qu'il est
arrivé il ya cinq ans mais il peut
s'estimer les victimes mais si on
s'engage qu'on demande à des gens de
s'engager avec soin il faut avoir les
moyens d'aller au bout c'est l'essentiel
du problème mais ce que je sais ce que
je veux dire c'est autant je
considère que la candidature en tête de
liste détiennent et un dhimmi ce n'est
pas quelque chose qui est pays qui est
porteuse dans cette élection
autant l'homme est tout à fait
intéressant
à des compétences qu'il faudrait mettre
au service et si dia et anne desjardins
n'a pas annoncé sa candidature c'est que
nous laissons les choses ouverte je
pense que la réalité va s'imposer
etienne et azimut ce sera percevoir
qu'il rencontre un certain nombre de
difficultés qu'il a du mal à monter
cette liste et que la meilleure solution
c'est quand même que les gens qui
effectivement sont dans cette position
politiques se réunissent pour créer une
dynamique effectivement je suis
parfaitement d'accord avec lui la
situation politique dans le pays fait qu
il ya un rejet des deux partis
hégémoniques aujourd'hui est que si nous
sommes capables de montrer notre
capacité à bien gérer la ville à bien
répondre aux attentes des saint cyriens
comme on dit a vraiment un coup à jouer
mais il effectivement il faut qu'on se
rassemble dans la meilleure organisation
possible voilà c'est le débat qui est
normal un peu moins d'un an d'aidé
municipale c'est normal au centre
leclerc dit si d'ici cet été je voudrais
juste préciser que nous avons sollicité
également le maire ump de cette commune
bernard de bain réagir à votre démission
il n'a pas souhaité s'exprimer sur ce
cas particulier est lui par contre
annoncé qu'ils seraient d'ores et déjà
candidats on aura l'occasion d'en
revenir de revenir sur ce point tout à
l'heure au cours de l'entretien mais
juste pour revenir sur votre cas 89
votre arrivée au sein du conseil
municipal ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure
quel regard vous portez sur cette
commune de saint cyr vous évoquez des
tensions au niveau national cette
défiance de la population envers les
politiques mais sur la ville de saint
cyr l'école ya une situation
particulière aussi il a un maire élu la
ville était d'abord communiste le maire
ump a été élu il a démissionné pour des
problèmes 10 hier il ya un autre merci
s'est mis en place le conseil municipal
s'est divisée ya beaucoup de tension
dans cette commune de saint cyr l'école
dans l'opposition dans la majorité
depuis des années il ya beaucoup de
dévolution effectivement bon si on
parlait en termes d'évolution je pense
que
la chose qui touche le plus les saint
cyriens c'est le nombre de constructions
qui ont lieu je pense que ça transforme
la ville on a eu une première ac
aujourd'hui appelée zac du parc de
l'abbaye on a une deuxième vague 25
hectares mille quatre cent cinquante
logements c'est-à-dire 20% dans les cinq
ans qui viennent en gros on va voir 20 %
de logements plus avec tous les
problèmes les problèmes de circulation
de stationnement les problèmes d'accueil
des nouveaux arrivants aussi bien dans
les services publics municipaux que dans
les associations c'est une ville qui
bouleverse
effectivement il se trouve que la vie
politique est un peu chahuté elle avait
été très stables pendant 80 ans je sais
pas en train de se rattraper bon je
pense que tout tout tout tout ça se fera
mais effectivement quand vous avez une
majorité politique pendant 80 ans qui
est qui est en place c'est vrai que le
l'opposition quand elle part bien
arriver à prendre la majorité
elle un peu tout feu tout flamme
et que c'est assez difficile de ne pas
faire d'erreur dans ce cas là des
erreurs de gestion mais je dirais de
gestion humaine
dans les listes s'est pas complètement
indépendante ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure on va regarder juste une photo
j'aimerais vous faire réagir c'est un
homme politique du passé ascenseur
l'époux qui pourrait être également un
homme politique du futur philippe lavaud
c'est l'ancien maire ump justement c'est
lui qui avait démissionné pour des des
questions notamment judiciaires il se
dit qu'il pourrait éventuellement
revenir être candidat
lui aimerait bien être candidat aux
côtés de bernard de ben bernanke demain
sur ce plateau qui nous a expliqué qu'il
ne souhaitait pas l'avoir à ses côtés
jose ont été clair lorsqu'il était venu
sur cette antenne pour réagir quel est
votre sentiment sur son possible
probable retour hypothétique retour dans
la vie politique de sincère
qu'un ancien maire ump
envisage de se présenter contre le maire
en place ump
en fait je crois que la chose la plus
importante quand on voit ça c'est de se
dire que le maire en place
ne passe pas si bien on a eu un sondage
que je conteste pas ce qu'ils étaient
payés par les saint cyriens c'est
monsieur de bain veut un sondage pour
ses prochaines élections il a qu'a se le
payer mr effectivement demandé un fait
un sondage sur sa commune par rapport
aux municipales pour voir un petit peu
les rapports de force et là il est sorti
avec 38 % comme vous rappeliez tout à
l'heure au premier tour il y a 6 ans
cinq ans qu'il était à 100% depuis il a
un outil extraordinaire qui est le
magazine municipal qui est un véritable
matraquage et pourtant ils y laissent
alors bon les configurations un peu
différente puisqu'il ya notamment une
liste front national qui était testé je
sais pas si on aura une belle été testée
donc ça prend forcément des voix un
petit peu à tout le monde et ça fait au
moins 10%
on voit que les appétits des uns et des
autres sont en train de de s'aiguiser la
gauche
nous ce serait déjà pas mal sont modérés
citoyens enfin venu prendre le
vocabulaire que vous voulez l'ancien
maire ump qui se met aussi dans les
délais dans les starting blocks se veut
dire une chose très simple c'est que le
maire en place et remis en cause quelque
part par la population et nous qui
sommes proches de la de la population
nous le sentons bien que nous aurons
l'occasion bien sûr d'organiser des
débats sur cette antenne où chacun
pourra s'exprimer réagir sur ces
différents points est présenté enfin les
différents programmes même s'il nous
reste encore quelques mois d'ici là on
parlait à d'affaires judiciaires
justement alors pour conclure comme il y
en a beaucoup ces derniers temps au
niveau national nous avons voulu savoir
si votre confiance envers les élus
locaux ces responsables politiques qui
est organise la vie de la cité au
quotidien et bien savoir si vous étiez
toujours confiant envers leurs actions
voici vos différentes réponses je dirais
oui
parce qu'elle est bien géré on fait vite
dans laquelle j'habite aujourd'hui me
semblait à gérer je les connais très peu
je ne vois pas du tout
on n'est pas si mal que ça ici alors bon
je leur fais encore un peu confiance oui
toujours eu en moi parce que je le
connais depuis longtemps
quelques années jusqu'en temps ne on les
a élus et à nos locaux chez nous on a
priori on n'a pas trop de choses alors
c'est difficile avec franchement avec le
ce qui se passe actuellement
voilà il ya beaucoup de discours et puis
derrière on a du mal à voir vraiment
concrètement ce que ça donne donc non
c'est se compliquer leur faire confiance
j'y connais pas ça m'intéresse pas ça
m'intéresse pas la politique les disons
que moi je suis contente de mes élus de
la ville pas de poids du gouvernement
attention
micro trottoir réalisé sur les communes
de guyancourt et de
voisins-le-bretonneux juste pour
conclure votre réaction on voit que les
gens se raccrochent encore auprès de
leurs élus locaux c'est la dernière
barrière quelles que soient les
vicissitudes au bout de plus de 20 ans
de vie politique locale je peux dire
qu'ils ont raison de leur faire
confiance merci beaucoup il donne
beaucoup merci daniel fournier dont vous
étiez élu d'opposition vous êtes
toujours dans l'opposition une autre
manière en quelque sorte est
démissionnaire du groupe agir pour saint
cyr à saint cyr l'école et on verra dans
les prochains mois comment vous vous
positionnez ouvert que les différentes
candidatures qui seront posées à saint
cyr merci à vous